so doesn't romans chapter 1 verses 26
and 27 clearly condemned any and all
forms of same gender relationships and
sexuality that's the question I want to
jump into today so what kind of tabletop
where each week I unpack ideas and
insights from Christian theology and
spirituality that help you become a more
thoughtful column just a downright
wonderful human being my name is Brett
silver pastor at the table at church in
Sachse Texas and today is part four of
our series why I'm a gay affirming
Christian so the text will be jumping in
today is of course going to be from as
chapter 1 verses 26 and 27 and this will
be a much longer episode than usual
simply because really this passage it's
probably the single most frequently
cited text to condemn same gender
relationships from the Bible and so I
really want to do justice spend some
time on it now before we read that text
let me just say kind of a caveat I have
drawn very heavily from the work of
James Branson in his book Bible gender
sexuality as well as a number of online
lectures he has posted which you can
easily find by searching YouTube for
James Brownson that spelled with two O's
and then just search James Brown some
Romans 1 and you'll find lots of
material and just named very clearly I'm
not and a scholar doing original
research here I'm reading the smart
people trying to digest their ideas and
then delivering them to you so it's kind
of gross matter for a digest anyway so
let's start here in verse 26 Romans
chapter 1 it says this because of this
God gave them over to shameful lusts
even their women exchanged natural
sexual relations for unnatural ones in
the same way the men also abandoned
natural relations
with women and were inflamed with lust
for one another men committed shameful
acts with other men and received in
themselves the due penalty for their
error again Romans 1:26 and 27 now as I
mentioned before when dealing with a
text like this the key question we have
to ask is not nearly what the Bible says
but why it says what it says in other
words we have to discern the underlying
moral logic of the passage in order to
understand how it might apply today so
in a series of lectures on this passage
James Brown said he unpacks Romans he
covers verses 18 through 28 and he names
a variety of concerns the Apostle Paul
had that really helped point out the
moral logic underpinning this passage I
just want to go through and name these
first Paul is clearly concerned with
impurity verse 24 which of course came
just before the verses I began with
verse 26 it mentions this explicitly but
I would do want you to notice though
throughout the passage in here I have
the broader context of verses 18 through
20 in mind which you can look up and
read for yourself later that Paul he
really is talking about the internal
disposition of a person Paul says things
like their foolish hearts were darkened
and that they had quote sinful desires
that eventually led to like a form of
sexual acting out however 13 chapters
later in Romans chapter 14 verse 14 Paul
names that it's it's less though in an
outward an act that is either pure or
impure and it's more about the motive of
the heart in fact he says that quote
nothing is unclean
for you if you don't believe it is
unclean so this is really central to the
moral logic of not only Paul but the
entire New Testament especially Jesus
for example think of Jesus teaching in
mark chapter 7 verses 15 to 23 where he
describes how all evils arise from
within and how it's the heart that
defiles not a thing like an outward
thing right so it's not it's not an
outward form of like of a behavior or a
food or whatever it's it's it's prime
primarily it's an inner disposition that
is the problem so this is why throughout
Romans one pulse primary concern is the
internal disposition this this lack of
her strength this sort of internal moral
compass that knows no boundaries
so James Brown sin he names that it's
precisely this that quality that makes
the actions impure like that's the first
thing we've got to understand to get at
the moral logic is that Paul is very
concerned with impurity second Paul's
concerned with lust and with passion
verses 26 and 27 both described and
talked about shameful lusts and how the
men were inflamed with quote lust for
one another the idea in ancient world
was that to be controlled by lust or
what they called passion which is they
use the term differently than we do
today now that's like an awesome thing
you know I can follow your passion
that's they didn't think of it like that
was sort of passion and less sort of
similar in the problem the reason it was
a problem is it was to be controlled by
an outside force for example there are
quotes from the stoic philosopher Cicero
and the church father Christian church
father named Chris Austin that described
the lust and passion of pederasty that's
man-boy love in this way in in their
understanding this was driven not by
some sort of you know sexual orientation
but by an excess of desire Brownson also
believes that it's likely that paul has
the Roman
burr Caligula in mind Caligula was just
a downright evil person he would rape
women he would then and he would even
write men and then he would go back to a
dinner party and then talk about how
they performed I mean is awful he's an
awful person now by arguing that Paul is
concerned with lust and excess desire
this would push back on a more
traditional interpretation of Romans
chapter 1 verses 18 through 28 that
would want to say now it's all about
misdirected desire mm-hmm see that I
mean the tech scene is pretty clear it's
it's describing this sort of excessive
slightly over the top and maybe not
slightly very over-the-top sort of
lustful driven kind of desire all right
third Paul is concerned with what is
natural versus unnatural now verses 26
and 27 zero and on this point in
particular and in many ways this is the
linchpin of most not all but most
traditionalist arguments that utilize
Romans wanted to push back on a gay
affirming position so I'm gonna take
quite a bit of time with this in fact
this will have sort of its own sub
points so pointing to Romans 1 folks
will say that homoeroticism is simply
it's just unnatural and therefore
blatantly wrong in fact this I have this
conversation almost weekly with someone
who's more of a traditionalist and this
is pretty much where they come from
they're just like you know it sort of
like a gut feeling like just I just
never strong why just unnatural and then
we'll often for those more educated at
the point to Romans 1 see unnatural
however we have to understand how Paul
is using the terms natural and unnatural
in this context so let's get into a
little bit so the term translated here
into English as nature or natural is the
Greek term luciecox whose root is that
is the word
who sees now Lucy's it's not a Hebrew
word in fact it's not used by the
rabbi's until after the time of the
writings in the New Testament and even
then it's used by them when they're
trying to articulate ideas to Gentiles
like non-jews and the reason is that
that foo sees is a term that came to
Paul and other Jewish leaders from stoic
Greek primarily philosophy now according
to the Stoics foo sees has three basic
meanings so first it can refer to that
the nature of one's own soar the inner
disposition the doing of what comes by
instinct or what we would call what
comes naturally so as it so happens we
know Paul has this meaning in mind
because he uses this term foo sees again
just one chapter later in Romans chapter
2 verse 13 to say just this that that
Gentiles with when they those who do not
have the law that they become a law unto
themselves when they do he quote do by
nature the things required by the law
yes the turn thewe see so in other words
people who do good by instinct or by
doing what comes naturally they show
that they have the law within them so to
speak
all right so that's a good example for
him is chapter 2 it's the in early it's
the first meaning of foo cease doing
what comes naturally all right the
second meaning of who sees is doing that
which leads to communal well-being to
that which sort of everyone in a given
culture knows is conventional most would
agree that Paul deploy is the term in
this manner in another passage first
Corinthians chapter 11 verse 14 when he
asks this question he says does not the
very does not very nature teach you that
is a man
has long hair it is a disgrace to him
now compete that this moment would've
been great if I had long hair that
would've been awesome oh well missed
opportunity I wish I could've done a wig
now
clearly Paul is deploying the term in
nature in this context to mean that
which is commonly accepted by people in
a given culture just like in Paul's
culture you know for a dude to have long
hair that was sort of unnatural which
when he said when he said that he did
not of course mean that the hair of men
and his day didn't grow long naturally
of course everyone's hair grows but he
was simply saying it's it just wasn't
the given cultural norm right so that's
the second meaning of who sees the third
and final man you know who sees it
refers to the biological and material
world and the notion of living in
harmony with it thus when it comes to
the topic of the meaning of thewe sees
in relationship to sexuality in the
ancient world what most had in mind
would seem to be procreation for example
the great Hellenistic Jewish philosopher
Philo he wrote and let the man who is
devoted to the love of boys again this
is more evidence that most home erotic
behavior in ancient world was man-boy
love right beside so let me continue
this quote then start over and let the
man who is devoted to the love of boys
submit to the same punishment since he
pursues that pleasure which is contrary
to nature who sees and since as far as
depends upon him he would make the
cities desolate and void and empty of
all inhabitants wasting his power of
propagating his species
now this differs from the argument of
the most traditionalist on this topic
for example Robert Gagnon is the the
perfect sort of traditional scholar of
this who who tries to sort of extend
this line of thinking to the to the to
the plumbing doesn't fit argument but
rudely when he writes that the
complementarity of the anatomical parts
for mutual stimulation this is sort of a
loose quote from gap 9 and so he kind of
tries to say see this is what is talked
about the parts don't fit you know but
in the ancient world that appeal is
honestly never made now this is a key
insight because it seems to mean that
this is the linchpin in a lot of
traditionalist arguments you know it's
the whole the parts don't fit and
therefore it's not natural and therefore
God must be adamantly opposed to it but
notice that when an ancient writer is
referring to homoerotic behavior as
unnatural what they mean like at least
in the Philo example is that it is
non-procreative not that the plumbing
doesn't fit this is I got that line from
James Brownson now what Bronson goes on
to point out is that revisionists tend
to focus on the first and second
meanings of thewe sees talked about it
both while traditionalists emphasize the
third meaning while in the stoic vision
if they're actually trying to bring all
three together
however as modern leaders what we have
to begin to integrate into our own
position is I think new data that we now
have that inform how we interpret all
three points and all three meanings you
see on the moon on the meaning of who
sees for the individual right it's
essential and what comes naturally it's
essential that we we understand the data
that is now commonly known that in fact
sexual orientation is something deeply
biological and therefore difficult if
not impossible to change for example
numerous studies done the last 50 years
point to certain genetic hormonal and
biological influences that determine
or at least influence a person's sexual
orientation this means that what comes
naturally to an LGBT person is different
than someone who is heterosexual now on
the meaning of thew C's for the social
order in the community we all understand
that social norms are constantly
changing we have to be really careful of
declaring what is the norm from a
cultural standpoint to be a timeless
truth for all people in all places for
example used to become a place for
Christians to quote first Corinthians
11:14 two men with long hair to point
out you know what godless heathens they
were becoming but think about it today
if someone tried to preach that passage
in a sermon in most churches it just
wouldn't be that compelling in other
words what is natural for one community
or culture is not for another finally on
the meaning of thewe cease for the the
natural order you know the rise of birth
control has really begun to shift our
perspective on sex from the more stoic
vision of something directed purely
towards procreation and it's directing
us towards a deeper understanding of
sexuality as a profound act of two
people in a marital committed
relationship giving and receiving love
and affection now again this is a modern
shift in the meaning of sex that the
ancients like Philo probably never
envisioned okay so what does all of this
mean for our purposes today but what it
means is that Romans 1 is not the
knockout punch that I think most
traditionalists assume it to be and at
the end of the day we have to understand
that Paul is deploying stoic thought for
a certain rhetorical effect upon his
listeners he's wanting to stir a sort of
sense of righteous indignation in them
so that a bit later in Romans he can say
that actually you're no better than
and sort of like he sent them up and I
think what this means is that we should
be very hesitant before declaring on the
basis of Romans 1 that LGBT people who
are longing to experience the stability
and companionship of marriage are
therefore disqualified for never doing
so instead what we should insist on is
the heart of Romans 1 right that they
live in harmony with themselves others
in the natural world Lucy's right
biblical that they should keep their
hearts and minds pure that they should
never be driven by lust or the desire to
exploit or abused another person and
that instead they should live lives of
devotion and sacrificial love for their
spouses it seems to me that is exactly
what Jesus and even Paul were he alive
today would be most concerned about now
is that an interpretation of Romans 1
that I'm giving you do I know for
certain what Paul or Jesus or what I've
been able to say like in this no I I
don't know that I'm just I'm saying that
it seems to me that that does do at the
heart of the moral logic in the in the
heart be of the concern that Paul has in
Romans 1 alright that is all for a day
Congrats to those of you who hung in
here for this very long video if you
enjoyed this please go ahead and click
the like button comment below share the
friend and if you want to ensure you
don't miss future episodes you can go
ahead and subscribe to my channel on
YouTube or my podcast most anywhere
podcasts are offered by searching Brett
Tolbert tabletalk grace in peace